complexity  structural barriers  skepticism  injustice and discrimination  in the eu one in three women have  experienced physical and or sexual  violence  one in two have experienced sexual  harassment  and more than one in two young women  worldwide are affected by cyber violence  enough  the eu is taking action to end violence  against women and domestic violence in  europe  the eu wants to ensure better protection  of women online and offline including by  criminalizing cyber violence  better access to justice including  easier ways to report violence better  support to survivors such as sexual  violence referral centers specialized  shelters for victims an eu-wide helpline  number  training of professionals and awareness  raising to stop violence from happening  in the first  place let's act now to staff violence  against women  [Music]